twice the Targaryen strike to conquer
Dorne with soldiers twice they failed
only when the Dragon Kings came bearing
husbands and wives did my ancestors
relent and agreed to join their seven
kingdoms house Martell could have waged
war until the end of days but how could
we resist a peace we could take to bed
for centuries the Iron Throne had no
more loyal ally than the princes of
Dorne
since we had never fallen to them we
kept our ancestral title perhaps this is
what drew Rhaegar Targaryen to us his
royal parents had not produced a sister
for him to wait so he had to look
elsewhere for a princess and there was
only one in Westeros Elia of house
Martell my sister she was not the most
beautiful woman in the world or even in
Dorne but rare for a woman from our land
her flower came with no thorns she was
kind and clever with a gentle heart I
loved her I feared for her for years I
fended off lesser men from her but when
Rhaegar came even I failed
he was beautiful and the crowned prince
of the Seven Kingdoms and our mother had
worked so hard to secure the match how
could Elia not accept him they were Wed
and he took her from her home from those
who loved her and would die for her and
locked her in his red cape above his sty
of a city surrounded by false friends
she bore him a daughter and a son though
each almost cost her her life Elia loved
regard she obeyed him and he chose to
steal away Lyanna stark a pale northern
girl whose veins ran with ice like all
her people instead of disciplining his
faithless son King Aerys executed the
Starks when they came seeking justice
and ignited a revolt I know how the
maesters described they were now but
calling it Robert's rebellion does not
change what it was
the war of the usurper Dorne sided with
the crown for when we swear oaths we
keep them we needed no threats from King
Aerys though he made them anyway
locking Elia and her children in the red
keep to ensure our loyalty even in his
madness he knew that no true Dornishmen
would ever take up arms against our
beloved princess and that we would fight
to the death for whichever side she was
on at the Trident Dorne lost ten
thousand men and two princes my uncle in
the Kingsguard and alias gallant husband
Prince Rhaegar who was too slow or too
arrogant for Robert's Warhammer as
robert's army marched on King's Landing
the Mad King sent his own wife and child
away but kept my sister and hers inside
in his madness Aerys thought that the
Dornish had betrayed his son at the
Trident and was only too happy to
welcome his one true friend back into
his ranks Tywin Lannister
Lord Tywin's Army sucked his friends
City while Lord Tywin's son murdered the
king he'd sworn to protect all this
could have been forgiven war is terrible
and men must become terrible to wage it
but the Lannisters knew that as long as
my sister and her children Prince
Rhaegar heirs lived no usurper could
safely sit the throne so Lord Tywin's
dog sir Gregor Clegane the mountain made
Elia watch as he murdered her daughter
and dashed her infant son's head against
a wall then with her baby's blood still
on his hands he raped my sister and
murdered her when Lord Tywin later
presented their bodies to Robert
Baratheon wrapped in pretty Lannister
cloaks I have been told the red color
graciously hid the blood from men's eyes
the Targaryen stock of fire and blood in
Dorne
our blood is fire if Robert Baratheon
had dared set foot in Dorne during his
reign he would have lost the foot and it
is not even him we blame for Elia the
Lannisters think their gold buys them
power the Lannisters think their
Mountain buys them strength but if they
want peace they cannot buy it with
mountains of gold or one mountain of
steel they must pay in blood
you